Today we're going to look at
challenges to the Supreme Court,
uh,
in the Supreme Court to the death penalty.
In 1971,
a challenge was launched.
This was based on the due process
clause of the 14th amendment.
It was unsuccessful the
very next year in 1972,
another challenge was made,
but this time under the eighth
amendment of the constitution,
the cruel and unusual punishment
clause and it was successful.
This was the case of
Furman versus Georgia.
The declared the death
penalty unconstitutional.
But then just four years later,
after a number of states had
enacted new death penalty laws,
uh,
the supreme court upheld the death
pony at least for some states.
And we'll look at that struck
down the death only a four others.
Uh,
so we'll get a bit of history,
uh,
out of what we're going to look at,
in terms of the death penalty
and how it had been practiced.
And then we'll look at the procedures
that were adopted in 1976 and where the
court,
uh,
ha ha has gone.
Uh,
from there,
uh,
the first case I want to talk about it.
Mcgautha versus California.
This was a case out of,
um,
two states,
really.
California mcgautha himself and a phoneme
Wilkerson were appealing of state out
of a,
excuse me,
appealing a Dustin's out of California.
Uh,
and uh,
James Edward Crampton was appealing
his de essence out of Ohio.
Now,
there were differences in the way these
cases were treated back at this time.
The,
the,
the California case
involved a bifurcated trial.
That meant there was one trial on
guilt or innocence and one trial,
uh,
with regard to punishment
with regard to sentencing,
uh,
the Crampton case which came out of Ohio,
had what was pretty much the
standard practice at that time.
One trial and the jury decided both guilt
and punishment and basically the way
it worked was the jury,
if it found the person guilty of murder
could come back with a recommendation of
mercy,
in which case the judge would impose
will a sense of life imprisonment.
Or if there was no
recommendation of mercy,
uh,
then the death sentence will be imposed.
So two different practices.
Crampton is much more
universal in terms of the wave
statutes worked at that time.
Um,
this is,
I say,
based on the due process clause,
uh,
of the,
14th amendment and basically
what they're saying,
as I said,
California two phase
trials we've talked about.
Now notice the difference
here and California,
the jury is instructed that
it may be influenced by pity,
sympathy,
uh,
or mere sentiment.
Uh,
in Ohio the jury is told it must not
be influenced by sympathy or prejudice.
So different practices
in the different states,
uh,
the is in both these and Ohio,
and excuse me,
California,
they're specifically instructed,
um,
that they're entirely
free to consider anything,
uh,
with regard to their judgment conscience.
There absolute discretion whether
to impose the death pony or not.
Uh,
in Ohio,
uh,
they're basically just told if
you find them guilty of murder,
uh,
then he's going to get
the death pony unless you,
uh,
impose,
unless you make a recommendation of mercy.
Uh,
so both of these people,
uh,
the California people and cramped in,
in Ohio are basically saying there's
no guidance given to the jury here,
uh,
about when,
the death penalty can be
imposed and when he can't,
there are no guidelines or the jury's
not told what it can consider a and what
it can't.
Uh,
so the question that's before the court
in mcgautha is what weight do we give to
the fact that this has been
the established practice?
Uh,
pretty much throughout the history.
At one time we had mandatory death
sentences for a number of crimes that was
softened somewhat by the legislatures
when they went to this additional
provision for mercy as the
jury having that option.
So that if the jury felt
like the person yes,
was guilty of murder,
but no,
they shouldn't be executed,
they could add mercy to their,
to their verdict,
uh,
the,
the court looks at this and basically
just to put it in everyday language.
Well,
we've always done it this way.
Uh,
why would we do it differently?
Now a justice,
uh,
Douglas suggest that,
maybe,
uh,
the requirements of
due process can change.
Or as he says,
he evolve,
uh,
as time goes by.
Uh,
and then the question that,
that these people are putting before the
court is how important is consistency?
They're saying the jury and our case
could impose the death penalty for any
reason.
The jury and another case
can impose if for any reason,
so cramped and may get the deaf,
Colleen mcgautha may get the death pony
when somebody else a guilty of a crime,
um,
equally or maybe far more heinous than
those crimes does not get the death
point.
It's that create a constitutional problem.
Uh,
and is it possible to tell a
judge and a jury ahead of time?
These are the factors
that you must consider.
And deciding whether or not
the death point should impose,
uh,
be imposed.
Well,
in 1971,
supreme court said it's not possible.
Uh,
and mcgautha the court says
to identify before the facts,
the characteristics of the criminal,
uh,
homicides and the perpetrator,
which can be taken into account to decide,
uh,
whether a desk should be imposed or not.
Our task beyond our ability,
uh,
this is not something we can do.
And the court goes on to say that it is
impossible to say that committing to the
complete discretion of the jury,
uh,
the power to enter the,
to impose the death sends a offense.
Anything in the constitution.
Basically the courts
saying Justice Harlan,
a writing for the majority,
uh,
saying,
um,
if a jury has given the
awesome responsibility of
whether or not to impose the
death penalty or not,
it will make that decision
in good conscience.
And this is what we rely upon,
uh,
in terms of making sure that this
punishment is imposed in a reasonable way.
Uh,
justice Douglas and Brennan a dissent,
uh,
saying,
surely the states can
create some guidelines.
There's gotta be some information given
to the jury about what information it
can consider,
what information it can consider,
but that draws only three votes.
Uh,
in 1971 a year later,
the court is going to come to
exactly the opposite conclusion.
Uh,
now the court is going to look at
this under the eighth amendment,
the cruel and unusual punishment clause.
The Eighth Amendment provides that
excessive bail shall not be required or
excessive fines imposed.
And then the part we're interested in nor
cruel and unusual punishment imposed a
number of cases that are in the
materials that accompany the clarity.
They're part of the class,
uh,
that most of the supreme court
cases up until this time,
uh,
had been about the method,
the way in which a person is executed.
Is it unusual to shoot someone,
uh,
in Utah for our crime?
Supreme Court said that's not unusual and,
uh,
you could,
could carry out an execution that way.
Electrocution electrocution was first
introduced challenge to the practice of
electrocution and the Supreme Court said,
states can use electrician,
uh,
electrocution.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
Willie Francis his case on Louisiana,
they tried one time to execute Willie
Francis and it wasn't successful.
And so the question was,
can you try a second time,
uh,
to put a person to death?
And that case made it made its way to
the supreme court before they try it a
second time.
Uh,
and Supreme Court said you
could and Willie Francis
was executed by the state of
Louisiana.
But,
but those,
those decisions not very
helpful for people challenging
the death pony under the
eighth amendment.
Uh,
but there are a couple of
cases that are important,
uh,
as sort of the backdrop,
for the Supreme Court's decision,
uh,
in Ferman.
Uh,
the first is a case that came
out of the Philippines when,
uh,
it was a territory of the United States
in cases would be reviewed by the United
States Supreme Court called
Weems versus United States.
Uh,
Williams was severely punished for the
crime of falsifying a public document.
And the Supreme Court decided in the case
that the punishment was too severe for
the crime,
uh,
that he was imprisoned.
He was a,
in a hard labor perpetual,
uh,
surveillance,
number of,
uh,
harsh,
and severe penalties imposed
for just falsifying a document.
And here we get some tools that the
supreme court uses when it looks at the
death penalty that the cruel and unusual
punishment clause may acquire meaning
as public opinion becomes
enlightened by humane justice.
In other words,
the cruel and unusual punishment clause
of the eighth amendment is not limited
to just what it meant when it was adopted
at the time the bill of rights was
adopted at that time.
There were all sorts of punishments.
Uh,
there was a hanging shooting.
There was cutting off fingers branding,
uh,
a number of other kinds of punishments,
which the society doesn't
really use any more.
Uh,
and the Supreme Court and Williams says,
you look to what is,
what is society except today,
not what society,
except back in the 17 hundreds.
Uh,
it also introduces the notion that
a punishment may be excessive.
And the,
in determining that we look to the purpose
of the punishment and can the purpose
of the punishment,
uh,
be fulfilled without resort
to such a severe punishment.
In other words,
is there a way to punish falsifying
a public document or any crime,
including murder?
Uh,
that is less than the most severe sends,
uh,
that's imposed.
And if that's the case,
then it may be an excessive
unconstitutional sentence
as the sentence imposed
upon Williams was,
uh,
in,
under the cruel and
unusual punishment clause.
The other important cases,
troop versus Dallas,
a troop was denied.
He was naturalized,
uh,
as a result of a
desertion during war time.
And the question became,
is this punishment too much,
uh,
for uh,
leaving him stateless?
Is this too much of a,
too severe,
uh,
a punishment under the cruel and
unusual clause of the eighth amendment?
Uh,
the Supreme Court held that it was,
uh,
justice,
Chief Justice Warren riding
for four members of the
court says the basic concept
underlying the eighth amendment
is nothing less than the dignity,
uh,
of humankind.
Uh,
and it provides some important language,
which we'll be looking at
all through the course,
uh,
that the eighth amendment draws its
meaning from the evolving standards of
decency that mark,
uh,
the progress of a maturing society.
Again,
much like what we've said,
but at the court looks at what are
the evolving standards of decency.
The,
the eighth amendment doesn't necessarily
mean what it said at the outset,
as I said,
and finally and controversially
a but not at that time.
International standards are relevant.
Uh,
when they looked at the punishment
that had been imposed upon troop,
they said civilized nations
all through the world,
virtually unanimous against this
severe a punishment for this crime.
Uh,
the,
the one thing about
troop that is important,
it only got four votes.
Uh,
so it was not a majority opinion.
Justice Brennan wrote a concurring
opinion in which he laid out his,
uh,
understanding of the
cruel and unusual clause,
uh,
and joined in the outcome or
troops sentence was struck down.
Uh,
but that took a little bit away
from the force of this decision.
Nevertheless,
we get some concepts.
Here are some principles under the eighth
amendment from these two cases that
are going to come into play when the
supreme court takes up Furman versus
Georgia.
But first,
let's just back up.
Can you really make an argument that
the death penalty is unconstitutional?
Uh,
uh,
the constitution provides,
takes into account,
uh,
the idea of the death pone of the fifth
amendment to the constitution says no
one shall twice be put in
jeopardy of life or limb.
I suppose some would say it's even
constitutional to remove a limb.
Uh,
but that practice is pretty much,
uh,
been abandoned.
But,
uh,
they talk about putting
one in jeopardy of life,
not deprived of life
without due process of law.
And then in the 14th amendment,
uh,
adopted after the civil war,
once again,
uh,
the constitution says,
a person is not to be deprived of life
as well as liberty or property without
due process of law.
So the constitution itself
clearly contemplates that
the states and the federal
government,
uh,
will use the death pony.
So if the argument is going to be made
that the death penalty a violates the
constitution,
it's going to have to be based upon
something about the way in which the deaf
pony is imposed or the way
in which it's carried out.
It's not going to be that
the death pony is per se,
a violation of the constitution.
And that's the question
that came before the court.
And Furman versus Georgia.
Uh,
uh,
Farman was convicted of murder,
in Georgia.
William Henry Farman,
Lucius Jackson,
uh,
was convicted of rape
in Georgia at the time.
Fermin came before the court.
That death punny was given
for a number of crimes,
not only for murder,
but also for rape,
armed robbery,
kidnapping,
a number of other crimes,
uh,
Elmer branch also convicted of rape.
But in Texas,
uh,
these three defendants all convicted and
trial courts in the states of Georgia
and Texas,
and they bring this case to the
Supreme Court and ask it to answer this
question.
Uh,
does the death pally violate the cruel
and unusual punishment clause of the 14th
amendment?
Uh,
and so the court decides that it does,
but in one of the most
remarkable opinions,
uh,
maybe unprecedented in the Supreme Court,
no two justices can agree on why it does.
So we have five different
opinions and the majority,
and we have four separate opinions in
the minority and each justice has their
own take on what this phrase and the
eighth amendment means cruel and unusual
punishment.
Uh,
and so we don't come out of from and with
any sort of clear guidance as to what
the constitution does and does not allow.
But we come out with a lot of principals,
uh,
from the different judges' opinions,
which will be very important
in looking at the death.
Connie,
uh,
later on,
let's look first to justice Douglas.
As most senior judge,
uh,
justice on the court appointed
by Franklin Roosevelt,
he saw a desire for equality,
uh,
in the ban against cruel
and unusual punishment.
And he went back through a English
history at some lengths to talk about why,
uh,
one of the concerns of the framers
when they adopted the cruel and unusual
clause was,
uh,
equality in the way people were treated.
Uh,
also,
uh,
discrimination.
That of course relates to equality.
Uh,
a penalty is unusual because we
are dealing with a death pony.
So we don't have to really,
uh,
as the question of is it cruel?
A court is going to say the death
point is unlike any other penalty.
It's extraordinary penalty
because it just ends a human life.
Uh,
it's a revokable no way to go back and
change it if you find out you made a
mistake.
Uh,
but the question really is,
is it unusual,
uh,
under the cruel and unusual clause?
Uh,
Justice Douglas says it's unusual if
it discriminates by reason of race,
religion,
wealth,
a social position in class,
and he Marshall's a lot of evidence which
shows that the death penalty has been,
uh,
carried out in the country,
in a way in which it's certainly
fallen more heavily on,
uh,
African Americans in
particular at that time,
uh,
and almost exclusively on the poor.
Douglas says at one point,
in his opinion,
you can search in vain
for a wealthy person,
uh,
who,
who was sentenced to death.
Uh,
and what he's interested
in is the risk of these,
uh,
factors coming into play.
He didn't say you have to
prove that race motivated.
Uh,
the prosecutions in these cases or race
was the reason that the death penalty
was sought when life imprisonment
might've been a completely sufficient
punishment.
Uh,
but that the death penalty
is unconstitutional if,
uh,
there are procedures that give room for
the play of race and poverty to come
into account.
So that's,
that's one vote to strike
down the death penalty.
Uh,
next is,
is Justice Brennan,
uh,
Hoover importing to the court
by President Eisenhower.
Uh,
and he has basically a four part,
a way of looking at the cruel
and unusual punishment clause.
First of all,
he,
he goes back to this notion of dignity
that we got out of truth versus Dallas.
And he says,
a punishment cannot be
severe and degrading.
Even the convicted criminal
has a measure of dignity.
Uh,
and therefore there's some limit on what
kind of punishments can be imposed and
it can't be degrading.
Uh,
it cannot be arbitrary.
he says that the death
pony in terms of how,
and this is going to be a theme
we see throughout these opinions,
it smacks of little more
than a lottery system,
uh,
that some people get the death
pony and some people don't.
But there's no real basis that we can
discern except for race perhaps as to why
some people get it and others don't.
Third question he asked is,
is it acceptable to contemporary society?
Here again,
we're talking about the
evolving standards of decency.
Does the country today,
except it,
there were punishments,
uh,
as I said a moment ago,
like whipping people,
most people would say today that,
you know,
whipping has been
abandoned by every state.
And so is it acceptable
to contemporary society?
The answer probably know,
uh,
this is a punishment
that's been abandoned.
Uh,
such a,
so has branding,
so has cutting all fingers,
uh,
those kinds of punishments
once accepted in this country,
but no longer acceptable.
So does a contemporary society except it.
And then finally,
the notion that we saw in,
uh,
in Weems of excessive a will,
a less severe punishment
serve the same purpose.
Uh,
and so Brennan sort of ads
in this element of necessity.
Does the,
does the state need the death Tali,
uh,
to punish the crimes
that are involved here?
Rape and murder,
uh,
if it can punish those crimes
with life imprisonment and,
and serve the same interest
that the state has,
which is preventing people from committing
these crimes and punishing them,
uh,
if they do,
um,
well then we go to potter.
Stewart.
Justice Stewart is a republican appointee
appointed by President Eisenhower had
been on the Sixth Circuit
Court of Appeals and,
and,
um,
uh,
Cincinnati.
Uh,
he says it's unusual if
it's infrequently imposed.
Uh,
he says for murder,
it's infrequent and for rape,
it's extraordinarily rare,
uh,
that the death pony,
is imposed,
uh,
for that.
Uh,
and he used a very colorful language.
Capriciously selected handful,
uh,
receive the death pony while others who
commit crimes just as reprehensible do
not.
Here again,
we see this question of consistency are
some people getting the death penalty?
And some people,
not.
Stuart says receiving the death pony
is like being struck by lightning.
Uh,
there's no,
uh,
some people get it while others don't,
and there's no reason
for those distinctions.
So He's worried about,
uh,
the infrequency,
and also,
uh,
the capriciousness,
of the way in which the
death penalty is imposed.
Uh,
he goes on and talk about
a little bit about race.
He says my concurring brother and,
uh,
have demonstrate that if there's any
basis for why these few get the death pony
when many others,
uh,
don't,
it is the constitutionally
impermissible reason of race.
But he says
race discrimination has not been
proven and I put it to one side.
I simply conclude that the eighth and
14th amendments cannot tolerate this
unique penalty,
the death penalty to be imposed
in a wanton and freakish manner.
Uh,
and so again,
sort of colorful language that,
uh,
justice Stewart uses in describing
what he sees as problematic.
Notice though that Justice Stewart here
is not saying I find the death Polly
unconstitutional in all situations.
He's saying when it's freakishly imposed,
when it's very infrequent,
uh,
when it's like being struck by lightning,
which is the way the depth punny
had operated up until 1972,
at least according to his view of it,
then that makes it cruel and unusual,
unusual in the arbitrariness of it,
the infrequency of it.
A very important vote here.
Uh,
Justice Byron White pointed to the court,
uh,
by,
the only appointment by President John F.
Kennedy,
uh,
Justice White,
normally fairly conservative
on criminal law matters,
uh,
but he votes to strike
down the death polling.
He,
again,
like Justice Stewart talks
about the infrequency the
fact that the death penalty
is so seldom used,
uh,
that it doesn't really serve the deterrent
purpose that its supporters claim,
uh,
that it has.
Uh,
he also,
uh,
finds it excessive that there is
a negligible return to the states,
uh,
for enforcement.
Uh,
the,
this,
uh,
is more again,
gets into this,
uh,
question.
Uh,
the Brendan talks about,
about necessity,
uh,
the pointless and needless extension of
life with only marginal contributions
only marginally serves the state
purpose when it has another sentence,
which is,
can impose,
uh,
just as well as he said,
the legislative purpose
will not be frustrated,
uh,
because it can still punish.
And so we're not saying you can't punish
these crimes were just saying you can't
punish them.
Uh,
with the death valley,
you can punish them with life imprisonment
or a term of years or whatever.
And then finally and critically,
uh,
just as a white says,
there's no principled way to separate
the few who get the death pony from the
many who do not notice.
Again,
this is our second justice
now along with Stewart,
who's not saying I'm necessarily
opposed to the death pony,
but I'm opposed to it in the
way it's used infrequently,
uh,
arbitrarily,
and without any principle basis
for why some people get it.
And some people do not.
You read this opinion and you think,
well,
if there was a principle basis,
which is what the states are
going to try to do after farming,
uh,
you'd probably get justice white's
a vote to uphold a new death sins,
which we will see,
uh,
happens.
Uh,
I think justice white at the time,
uh,
and the court perhaps overall,
thought the death pony was on its way out.
I just a few years before Furman
was the only time in the late 1960s,
uh,
when the supreme court,
or excuse me,
when the public opinion polls show that
more people were opposed to the death
penalty a then support it,
the rest of the time zone has been
more support for the death penalty than
opposition to it.
Uh,
but beyond that,
the court had decided a case called
Weatherspoon versus Illinois,
which we'll talk about when we talk about
juries in which the court had talked
about excluding people from juries,
uh,
because of their position
on the death penalty.
And notice that a large segment of
the population was being excluded.
Uh,
and it sort of talked about the people
qualified or the people left behind is a
dwindling minority of people
who supported the death point.
In other words,
the,
the practice of imposing the death.
Polly had declined a
great deal in the 1960s.
Uh,
the,
uh,
public opinion polls tended to show people
who are opposed to the death penalty.
Uh,
and by 1972,
the court sort of looks back at all those
and things and it's been a moratorium.
No DeCinces had been carried out,
uh,
for some period of time.
And so the court thinks,
uh,
that death pony,
this is sort of a society,
American society like the English,
the French,
and,
and Scandinavians in so many other people
are ready to abandon the death point.
Uh,
what the court didn't anticipate
obviously was that the,
uh,
1968 presidential election and
president Nixon's running on,
uh,
being very tough on crime and crime
becoming a very big political issue.
Uh,
the public opinion polls had
changed dramatically by 1972.
The court's a little
behind the curve here.
Uh,
but it,
we'll find out soon that there's
more support for the death,
plenty,
uh,
than it thinks a justice.
Thurgood Marshall was
the only member as a,
I've mentioned the only member of the
supreme court ever actually handled the
death pony case.
He actually set in a chair,
uh,
you know,
back when very few black
lawyers who are practicing,
uh,
beside other African Americans and
represented them before juries in capital
cases.
He appealed death penalty cases.
He knew that innocent people,
uh,
could be sentenced to death
because he had seen that happen.
And one of his,
one of his own,
uh,
not sentenced to death but convicted.
And one of his own cases,
uh,
as far as just Marshall was concerned,
that death pony is purposeless vengeance,
morally reprehensible,
and he finds that retribution
is unacceptable as a purpose.
One of the debates that were going to
see within the court here is if we have
the death pony,
what government interests does it serve a,
if it serves a retribution,
is that a proper interest,
uh,
for a punishment to serve?
Uh,
does it serve rehabilitation?
Obviously the death pony doesn't serve,
uh,
rehabilitation.
Did Terrence,
uh,
does it deter?
Uh,
and we'll see the debate back and forth,
uh,
in the court,
both in this case in 1972,
Furman versus Georgia,
but also later in 1976
when the court addresses,
uh,
the new death pony statutes.
Uh,
but here also,
Marshall says the American people would
never support the death penalty if they
knew that it was imposed.
Discriminatorily and he Marshall's a lot
of statistics and a lot of historical
information and supported that.
One of the most dramatic being that since
the Justice Department started keeping
statistics,
uh,
on the death pony in 1930,
from 1938 until 1972,
there had been 455 people
executed for the crime of rape.
Uh,
405 African Americans.
One of the more damning statistics,
uh,
in our national history,
he also pointed out that innocent people,
uh,
had been sentenced to death.
Uh,
and it probably,
most people don't know that,
but if they did,
they probably wouldn't
support the death penalty.
And then finally picks up the theme that
Justice Douglas had set at the outset.
It's the poor,
the ignorant,
and the underprivileged
who get the death penalty.
A while.
People of means people who are
better off are and justice,
guilty,
uh,
and perhaps crimes just as reprehensible,
they escaped the death pony.
Uh,
so justice Marshall clearly,
uh,
believes that the death
police time has come and gone.
Uh,
he and Justice Brennan would oppose and,
and Justice Douglas probably,
uh,
the death pony in,
in any case.
Uh,
but then we have two justices,
as I said,
just to Stewart and justice white who
find that because of the way the death
plenty is imposed as they see it
in 1972 arbitrarily freakishly,
uh,
that it's unconstitutional.
Um,
so let's look at the dissenters.
Uh,
Chief Justice Warren Burger trucks about,
and this basically,
if we want to look at
what divides the majority,
the five justices in the majority.
All right.
Separate opinions,
the four and the minority.
All right.
Separate opinions.
But what is the basic
separation between the two?
Uh,
and I believe it's what,
uh,
Justice Burger trucks about here,
the primacy of the legislative role.
The dissenters believe this is a
question for the legislature's.
Uh,
it's not a question for the court to take
up the five and the majority feel like
this is a constitutional issue.
Does the death penalty violate the
eighth amendment of the United States
constitution?
Uh,
and that's a judicial
determination to be made.
A Burger also points out that the
death penalty is not a repugnant.
He looks at these,
uh,
other eighth amendment cases,
as I said earlier,
about whether a particular method shooting
electrocuting trying a second time,
uh,
do those things violate the
criminal unusual punishment?
He says this is not like a burning
people at stake or those types of things.
This is a,
a,
a punishment that,
uh,
is not only a accepted,
it's not universally condemned.
He points out that 40 states
and the federal government,
uh,
have the death pony.
The federal government had even
added some desk statutes in the,
in the last decade.
Uh,
and then here's the interesting,
a division between the
majority and the minority.
We see the justices in the majority,
the five talking about how unusual the
death pony is and how infrequent it is.
A Justice Burger turns us around looking
at it from another angle and says the
infrequency shows the jurors are very
cautious about imposing the death Pollock,
uh,
that they are very cautious
and whether to impose it.
So you look at the same set of facts,
the fact that the death
penalty is imposed,
a hit here and there,
uh,
in different parts of Georgia,
different parts of Texas and other states,
uh,
one group of justices sees
that as arbitrariness.
Uh,
there's like being struck
by lightning just as burger.
And some of his colleagues in dissent
see that as juries are very careful when
they're given a person's
life in their hands.
They're very careful about,
uh,
whether or not to impose
the death penalty.
So,
um,
you can look at sort of the same
facts as the court does here,
uh,
and see two different realities.
But the primary one for Justice Burger,
uh,
is that this is something that
courts shouldn't be involved in this,
that we are to leave it
to the legislature's.
Uh,
same thing for justice.
Blackmun.
Uh,
justice Blackmun had never
liked the death pony.
He had made that clear when he was on
the United States Court of appeals and he
looked at a death penalty case side.
Well,
many death,
plenty of case,
but one in particular how to Arkansas.
Uh,
and he talked about how difficult it
was for him to sit on these cases.
Uh,
but he said it's a legislative judgment.
whether a state has the duff punny
or not is up to the legislatures.
We as justices on the supreme court should
respect what the state legislature's
do.
Uh,
Justice Powell,
uh,
pointed again by all of the dissenting
justices appointed by President Richard
Nixon after his election in 1968.
Uh,
just as Palestinian,
first of all,
if we're looking at the
evolving standards of decency,
uh,
we want to look at what
the legislatures have done.
Again saying,
we defer to the legislatures
and his Burger had pointed out,
40 states had the death pony at this time.
Of course,
many of them were not using it.
Uh,
it was being used primarily
in the southern states,
but it was on the books,
uh,
in a number of other other states.
Uh,
and Powell again takes issue with this
notion that the fact that it's not being
imposed very often is some indication
that the death penalty has been rejected
by modern society,
which is what,
uh,
Justice Brennan says when he talks
about is it acceptable to contemporary
society.
He looks at how few death
cases are imposed and says,
uh,
basically the,
the country has turned its
back on the death pony.
A pal says,
well,
uh,
not so fast.
The death penalty was imposed a
about two depth pennies a week,
uh,
or imposed throughout
the country in the 1960s.
Uh,
and then on Brendan's notion of necessity,
which also seems to be a little
part of Justice White's opinion,
uh,
power responds to that by saying there's
nothing in the constitution that says
that a penalty is invalid.
Just because there's a lesser penalty
that would serve the same purpose.
In other words,
what white is saying and what Brennan is
saying is that the states don't really
need the death poly.
It's serving only a marginal value
because they can punish these crimes with
life imprisonment.
Just as saying,
there's no constitutional rule that says
a state has to use the lesser penalty.
Uh,
and that that's a reason for
striking down the greater penalty.
Um,
he also talks about race,
uh,
but in a sort of resigned way,
just as Powell says,
it's always the poor and minorities,
uh,
that are treated poorly,
who get punished.
Uh,
but he said the reason for that is
because they grow up in poverty.
Uh,
there's not the parental and,
uh,
other supervision and that what we
really ought to do is deal with the root
causes of poverty and income inequality,
uh,
and not abolish the Death Poli.
Uh,
and then he seems to suggest that race
is not really that big a factor anymore.
Uh,
he said the great race has greatly
diminished because now we have blacks hung
juries when we come to juries.
Will see that's not the case even today.
Uh,
but it certainly wasn't the case in 1972,
uh,
when Justice Powell said that,
because at the time,
uh,
prosecutors were able to strike
African Americans from jurors.
And of course,
if you've got a group that's
in a minority to begin with,
uh,
it's going to be fairly easy for the
prosecutor to use his or her discretionary
strikes,
what we call a peremptory
strikes to exclude people.
So,
uh,
still in a lot of places where the
death pony was being concerned was being
imposed.
A,
there were not any blacks on the jury
and there weren't any African Americans
anywhere in the decision making
process in the prosecutor's office,
which decides whether to seek the death
penalty or whether it a plea bargain.
The cases,
uh,
no,
black people on the bench and judges and,
and most of the states,
particularly the states,
uh,
and generally cases being
tried to all white juries.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
we talked about history
in an earlier session,
uh,
and the role that the criminal justice
system has played in racial oppression
and throughout the
history of this country,
uh,
from the time of slavery to convict
leasing to mass incarceration today,
uh,
Powell says,
well,
past discrimination,
uh,
is no reason to strike
down the death point.
And this is a question
that we will wrestle with.
To what extent,
uh,
do we look at the past?
Do we look at how much this history,
this utterly corrupt criminal justice
system that sent convicts out,
uh,
into the fields and to the
railroads and the coal mines,
uh,
that,
helps slavery by providing for
the deaf 20 for so many people?
Uh,
to what extent is that
bleed into the present?
Uh,
and to what extent have we have
the criminal courts overcome it?
Uh,
but that will take up,
uh,
as,
as we go forward.
Uh,
finally,
uh,
we have,
Justice Rehnquist and Justice Rehnquist,
uh,
says that,
again,
uh,
the court is not a roving commission.
He again is going to defer
to the legislature's,
uh,
is not going to strike down laws based
upon what he says is just the majority.
It's just making a policy
determination here.
Uh,
he says a decision by unelected judge
that something is constitutionally
prohibited,
uh,
interferes with the right of
people to govern themselves.
If the people of Alabama or Texas
or Georgia one have the depth pony,
the court should,
uh,
let them have it.
Uh,
and his main point,
judicial self restraint,
uh,
that the judges should,
again,
as I said,
the primary difference between those and
the minority and those are the majority
is what's the judicial role here?
Is the judicial role to examine this and
decide whether or not the death penalty
is constitutional or is it to stand
back and let the legislature's decide,
uh,
whether they're going to
have the death penalty,
what crimes will be punished by the
death point and how juries or to come to
their decision.
But the end result of this is the death
pony is declared unconstitutional as
applied in 1972.
This resulted in a,
the end of the death
pony for the time being.
Every person about 560 people
were on death row at the time.
Ferman was decided,
uh,
this decision affected not only the
people in Georgia where Furman came from
and,
and Texas,
uh,
but it affected all the death sentence,
the state and federal
throughout the country.
And,
and,
and we sort of get this
out of these cases,
uh,
the notion of arbitrariness,
as part of the notion of unusual,
the process of imposing the
death pony must be rational.
There's got to be some principled
basis to distinguish the few.
This is going back to
justice white's opinion.
A few who get the death Polly,
uh,
from the many who do not.
Uh,
Justice Douglas says there's gotta be
some protection in any death pony statute
that prevents the risk of discrimination
based on race or poverty or,
or other factors.
So we come away with that as sort of a,
uh,
an eighth amendment principle,
out of these cases.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
this notion of the evolving
standards of decency,
uh,
the meaning of the eighth amendment.
Can change what it meant.
Uh,
and,
uh,
1970,
in 1776 a is not necessarily
what it means today.
Uh,
punishments that,
uh,
did not violate the eighth
amendment then may violate it today.
Uh,
as I said,
society has reached a consensus that some
punishments are no longer acceptable.
At the time of the
founding of the country,
uh,
there were no presence.
And so people were often
punished physically,
uh,
with say whipping.
Uh,
but today,
if some state enacted a statute that said,
we are going to provide a 10 lashes
for the crime of shoplifting,
uh,
probably the supreme court would say
that violates the eighth amendment cruel
and unusual punishment clause because
society has basically abandoned if there's
not another state,
49,
the other 49 states don't use
whipping a as a punishment anymore.
And therefore,
even though it was constitutional,
uh,
at the time the eighth
amendment was adopted,
uh,
not constitutional today.
But here's the problem.
How do we decide what the
evolving standards of decency are?
Uh,
do we measure it by what juries do,
which is what Justice
Brennan talked about.
Do we look to legislatures,
which is what the dissenters talked about.
Do we look at public opinion polls?
Uh,
we will see going forward that the supreme
court is going to wrestle with this,
uh,
for some time about how to measure
the evolving standards of decency.
It's easy in the examples that I gave.
If no other state is using
a particular punishment,
then you can say society
has turned its back on it.
Well,
but what if 20 states are using it in
30 or not a what if in the 20 that are
using and it's only being
used every now and then,
uh,
and the juries aren't
imposing it very often,
uh,
has society evolve to the point that
that's no longer an acceptable punishment.
But we will see that with regard
to the death punny in general.
Uh,
and we will see that with regard to the
death penalty for a certain kinds of
crimes,
accomplices,
for example,
uh,
and for certain people,
children,
uh,
have the,
the society except anymore,
uh,
the death penalty for children.
Does it accept the death pony for
people who are intellectually disabled?
Uh,
and we will get to all those,
uh,
in,
in the future.
Uh,
but we see today the court beginning to
wrestle with how it's going to decide on
the evolving standards of decency,
a proportion or excessiveness
necessary justice Brennan a suggest,
as we talked about the need for a
relationship between the severity of the
punishment and the government purpose.
The government wants to punish
people for the crime of murder.
Uh,
it does.
So,
and,
and Georgia and Texas by
providing for the death penalty.
Uh,
but the question is,
uh,
if they have life imprisonment,
is it necessary to have the death poem?
And Douglas would,
eh,
would add,
particularly if it's discriminating.
Uh,
and I don't think there's
much question today,
uh,
that certainly,
throughout our history,
the death pony has been used in a
discriminatory manner that it was a
particularly against African Americans,
both during the time of
slavery and up until 1972,
uh,
after the civil war,
was over.
Uh,
and then the notion of dignity,
uh,
which was,
what Chief Justice Warren thought was
the central principle of the eighth
amendment and truth versus Dallas.
Uh,
we're going to see two
different notions of dignity,
uh,
hear from the court,
but Justice Brennan's concern,
uh,
about the punishment not be
being unnecessarily degrading.
Uh,
Justice Arthur Goldberg,
who had been on the court
before once said that,
uh,
the deliberate institutionalized
taking of human life as the ultimate
degradation,
uh,
of a human being.
Uh,
and so for Brennan,
that answers the question right there.
But we will see later,
uh,
that for other justices,
what dignity means is you take into
account the individual characteristics of
the person,
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
you don't allow the death penalty all
together.
Uh,
and then this notion
that death is different,
that somehow the procedures,
uh,
are going to be a more careful,
in cases involving the death pony because,
uh,
the death penalty is era.
Vocable eliminates a person
from the human community.
Uh,
and the courts have to be very careful,
uh,
with regard,
to,
uh,
the,
fairness and reliability
in which the death pony,
uh,
is imposed clear that as we've discussed
that not all five members of the
majority think the death penalty
is always unconstitutional.
The four and the minority
clearly think to death.
20 is unconstitutional.
Uh,
con is constitutional and would
defer to the legislatures as soon as,
uh,
firmer was decided,
a number of states,
Georgia,
Florida,
Texas,
among them start passing
new death penalty statutes,
35 states in all.
Uh,
and that's what we'll review next is
when the court comes in 1976 to look at
those statutes and decide whether or
not they're constitutional or not.
We'll see.
The court upholds some and
find some others do not
satisfy the eighth amendment.